bavure ou frappe délibéré pour la
première fois dans le conflit ukrainien
pays membres de l'OTAN était frappé en
Pologne à la frontière ukrainienne deux
explosions dont l'une a détruit une
ferme est tuée de personnes missile
débrie de missiles des roquettes des
bombes et surtout qui attirés les
conséquences pourraient être très graves
puisque l'article 5 du Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord stipule que tout
agression sur un État membre
déclencherait une riposte de l'ensemble
des 30 pays de
l'otanos
le président Andreï Douda dit qu'il
réagit calmement tout en précisant qu'il
n'y avait pas encore de preuve sur qui a
tiré sur le village polonais
il s'est entretenu avec le président
byden et le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
sur le recours possible à l'article 4 du
traité convoquant une consultation de
tous les membres sur la situation
mais pour le Président zzinski il ne
fait aucun doute que les Russes sans
coupables
en Ukraine les sirènes d'alerte de la
défense anti-aérienne retentit en
après-midi et quelques minutes plus tard
des explosions étaient entendus
notamment à Kiev vivent à l'ouest et
harki vos nord-est les missiles ont été
tirés depuis la mer Caspienne la région
de Rostov est aussi depuis la mer Noire
selon le ministère de la Défense qui
affirme que sur les 90 premiers 70 ont
été interceptés c'est une des frappes
les plus massives de l'armée russe trois
jours après son abandon de la ville
stratégique de heerson et sa région à
Kiev ou deux immeubles résidentiels ont
été touchés au moins deux personnes sont
décédées et indiquer le maire de la
capitale vitaliclisco
les missiles ont endommagé surtout les
réseaux énergétiques rendant la
situation critique dans tout le pays
dans la capitale au moins la moitié des
habitants sont sans électricité et
l'opérateur national a déclenché des
coupures de courants
des explosions se sont fait entendre
Alves et on pouvait en voir la fumée
depuis centre-ville les habitants ont
été invités à rester à l'abri une partie
de la ville est restée sans électricité
vive se trouve non loin de la Pologne
qui pour la première fois a été frappé
elle aussi Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada Montréal